hong kong's upcoming election is less
about electing and more about selecting
the chinese government is trying to
cross out the candidates it doesn't like
for example these opposition lawmakers
were elected to the legislative council
in
2016.
now they
along with others are either in jail or
in exile
and the rest they're not allowed to run
because they're not considered patriots
a new rule imposed by beijing
being a patriot in hong kong also means
to be supportive of chinese communist
party leadership not only over china but
also increasing the over daily life
society and politics in hong kong so
being a patriot also means being loyal
to the chinese communist party um to
a large extent
and to ensure that only so-called
patriots can oversee hong kong beijing
has imposed a massive overhaul of the
electoral system
all candidates must be approved by a new
seven-member vetting committee and pass
a screening by the national security
police after the change of the electoral
system
the elections are coming will be totally
illegitimate
it has turned into
i mean the
parliament to be elected
would have
turned into a total rubber stamp of
beijing with no democratic elements in
it at all
teto was one of hong kong's opposition
lawmakers he is now in exile in
australia
after beijing imposed the controversial
national security law
as a former legislator myself looking
back at the place where i worked and the
chamber where
i spoke and i fought for democracy with
my colleagues
now it's no longer a place
that belongs to the people and so
of course
we have anger
like the hong kongers how
uh beijing has uh ruined of
our limited freedom and democracy in the
council
hong kong's leader disagrees
cary lam who is seen by many as
beijing's puppet insists that the
electoral changes can ensure the city's
stability
what we are now seeing is
deficiencies in the electrical system
which
could be exploited by
people including some external forces
and this is only right
in terms of
political ethics
how could one who is governing a place
who is not patriotic to that the country
it is inconceivable
hong kong's legislature has never been
fully democratically elected before the
current changes only half of the seats
in the legislative council were elected
through direct votes
but now doses have been further reduced
[Music]
under quarter of the 90 seats will be
elected through universal suffrage
another 40 will be chosen by an election
committee composed mostly of probating
pro-establishment business leaders
the remaining 30
will be elected through so-called
functional constituencies which
represent several industries and
professions this expert believes these
electoral changes were inevitable
after years of protest which had
displeased beijing so you had very large
demonstrations in 2014 with the umbrella
movement in 2019
and what began as an anti-extradition
bill
demonstration but you also had large
protests in hong kong earlier than that
in 2003 and in 2012 and i think what's
important about the protests of some of
those years is they actually got the
government to reverse course on things
so
beijing in some ways the chinese
communist party leadership got
frustrated with the fact that even
though
the local authorities were
trying very hard to do things to stay in
beijing's good graces
that there still was more room for this
kind of pushback than the communist
party wanted to see
so in sunday's election
153 candidates will be running
a couple of them are standing as
independents but none of them belongs to
any opposition parties
some activists like ted hoy are urging
people to cast blindfolds as a way to
protest
now the electric system has changed
like so ridiculously
and it's meaningless for quite many home
homers
to participate in the elections as if
it's real it's no it's illegitimate and
there's not many ways you can do it
legally to mobilize people politically
so uh but if you go to vote and if we
there's a collective action of protest
folks i think that means something to
the regime at least to embarrass them
and then it's also a clearer picture for
the international community to see how
angry people are that's why i i i think
it could be a good idea if
at least some amount of people will do
it collectively to kind of blindfold
but hong kong authorities have already
been trying to prevent election boycotts
they've issued charges against people
who call them photos not to cast ballots
that represents another way in which
these elections are far from being free
and fair